five seasons in you guys have built the
community your family
um and here we are nearing the end of
the show for the viewers i want to know
from each of you
if you could describe in one word what
the fifth
season is like you gotta give me that
one word nicole you popped into late so
you're gonna start with you
okay one word for the fifth season
um uh dangerous
dangerous kia bloody
of course tell me about it
alex
insane pressure
uh i'd say expansive
okay cool and kelly you know the word
that keeps popping up for me is just
dark yeah
what given the legacy so far of the show
like what do you want your fans to be
left with at the end what impact do you
want the fifth season to make
mean me personally i i just love
i want them to feel some kind of closure
with the characters with the story
um you know everybody's been through so
much
i want them to feel satisfied um
yeah i want i want them to
just walk away um
feeling like they saw something from the
beginning to the end
um yeah trisha nick oh sorry alex good
job yeah i feel the same way i think the
the coolest thing about
the five seasons and what people are
going to walk away with
is the the writers and the team actually
putting together some
interesting character developments to
where it really sucks in
uh the viewer and and that that's a it's
a testament to the fans of what you see
on twitter and instagram and
all that that how how vested they are
within the
within the the van helsing family and i
think
um that what kelly said is just the
completion of these characters that they
can
they can like go to bed knowing there
was a beginning middle and an end
yeah and given how like you said how
vested the fans are on the series
kia nicole and trisha i'm curious for
you what it felt like coming in
to this show with this like huge
established fan base already
um you know that was already kind of
like a well-off machine
walking into this fan base was pretty
incredible i mean everybody's so
welcoming
and they make sure you know it online or
even in person
because we all got the pleasure of going
to comic-con uh you know
sadly we didn't get to redo that this
year but it's
they make sure it feels like a family
and you feel extremely welcomed
and i hope we do the same thing for them
kia exam way it's been um
so amazing joining this family even
though
um it's been such a wild ride and i hope
that when the fans see
this final season that they feel closure
but they also feel a lot of fun
for the ride that the writers get to
take them on and all the actors involved
i hope they enjoy the ride yeah
kelly and trisha what was it like for
you getting to put
your own spin on these sort of classic
characters that people are familiar with
you know i felt like um the
the writers and the creators really gave
me an opportunity to just do something
totally new
and in a lot of ways it was the title
um but we flipped so many things on on
its head with
with van helsing um that i really felt
like i was creating something
new and that i wasn't tied down to any
stereotypes
um and i think that was one of the
one of um the several wonderful things
about being involved with this show was
the
um creative freedom uh so i really felt
that with my character
trisha yeah i agree with that um
i mean i came in basically in the final
season i had two
two kind of introductory episodes in
season four so really season five is
um the epis the season that i'm in and
obviously a culmination of the story of
the van housings you're gonna have to
bring in
dracula at the end right um but very
much like kelly said
uh it again like i i
i had to fit into the show that was
already there it wasn't like i was from
the beginning and
making the story like like kelly and
alex and
and and uh jonathan and you know the
rest of the crew that were there in the
beginning
but uh i also felt very
free to kind of just make the spin
on the dark one or dracula
we call it the dark one every once in a
while we say dracula um
my own and you know to my knowledge
there'd never been a female before so i
thought it was very fitting to be in a
show that was very female
centric and female driven um that there
was a female dracula and
but yeah aside from discussions with the
the
team on you know look and
feel it just i felt very free
to put my own spin and interpretation on
um so i didn't feel like i had any
limits at all which was
which was nice sometimes i want
parameters i'm like what are you guys
looking for so i
i know i can fit within that but uh i
really had no
no parameters given to me it was just
here's the character go with it
and what's really what's interesting
about that is that everyone was guessing
we knew that dracula was going to get
cast but everyone was going
i wonder who it's going to be and we had
you know and
as it did wasn't supposed to be cher
initially
that that name was thrown around that
was that name was thrown around
but it was so interesting as as a dude
just immediately
what dude are they going to cast for
dracula like you go in
like that's what a dude would go into
when i heard it was trisha
it was like of course this is amazing
and
i think the best part of this show um
you know
and kelly plays it wonderfully is that
how much of a hero
a female can be and i think it's a
testament to the writers and it's a
testament to how
trisha kelly um all the women on the
show are showing such badass natures and
some compassion and vulnerability
but also can kick some ass and that's
one of the proudest things about
this show that i feel like it really
kind of carried through the whole five
seasons
you know there's one thing i'm just
going to add to that alex is and not to
bring up a past
show but both alex and i were on it so
yeah
but one thing that van housing does very
well
in my um estimation is that
gender dynamic where you have all these
yes it's a female-centric show but that
doesn't mean the men are just like
you know minions on the side there is
there is none of that it's just
every character is a well-rounded unique
character
it didn't matter if it was men or women
or
vampire or whatever but like similar to
battle star which alex i know you were
on as well
um they had that same dynamic where it
wasn't about you know
the hot shot pilot was a woman they
never made anything out of it of her
being a woman
she just was the hot shot pilot that
didn't mean there wasn't other
hotshot pilots that were men or that
type of thing and i think that's what
van helsing did very well
also i feel like we took the gender out
of it and it was just badass people do
their thing yeah
you